THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CERVANTES.
CHAO CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRASER MEN.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
POPO.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOULD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESIDENCY ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER.
THESE PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IN HONOR OF MOTHERS DAY THIS
COMING SUNDAY.
I LIKE TO HEAR THE WISDOM OF MY
SISTER JAMIE MOTHER OF THREE.
WHEN YOUR CHILDREN WERE BECOMING
YOUNG ADULTS ONE NIGHT SHE
CALLED ME WAY PAST WHEN A. M..
IT WAS JUST DAYS BEFORE HER
MIDDLE CHILD WAS ABOUT TO BE IN
HER JUNIOR YEAR ABROAD. IN PARIS.
HEARING MY SISTER'S PENSIVE TONE.
I IMMEDIATELY ASKED WHAT'S WRONG
JEANNIE.
I KNEW THAT I WOULD NEVER FORGET
THAT EARLY MORNING CONVERSATION.
I QUIETLY SAID. I KNOW NOW WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE A MOM.
I ASKED HER WHAT IS THAT.
SHE SAID. BEING A MOM IS HAVING
TO LEARN TO LET GO.
THEN SHE WENT ON TO SAY. YOU
CARRY YOUR BABY FOR NINE MONTHS.
YOU GIVE BIRTH AND YOU HAVE TO
LET HER GO.
SOON HE'S TODDLING ALONG HOLDING
YOUR FINGER. THEN IN NO TIME SHE
IS RUNNING OFF AND YOU HAVE TO
LET HER GO.
THE DAY COMES WHEN THE TRAINING
WHEELS COME OFF THE BIKE. AND
YOU RUN ALONGSIDE HOLDING HER UP.
SHE SHOUTING MOMMY DON'T LET GO
MOMMY DON'T ECHO. YOU SAY I
WON'T I WON'T.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO LET HER GO.
THEN THEY GET THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE GO OFF TO COLLEGE.
AND THEN AFTER A PAUSE SHE SAID.
NOW MY BABY IS GOING TO FRANCE
AND I HAVE TO LET HER GO.
I LISTENED TO MY SISTER SHARE
THIS WITH ME THAT EARLY MORNING.
THEN I SAID TO HER. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
BUT AS I'VE BEEN TAUGHT. IT'S
NOT JUST BEING A MOM.
THAT IS WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
HUMAN BEING IN LIVING LIFE.
WE'RE ALWAYS HAVING TO LET GO.
I NEED A LIFE. NOTHING CAN LAST
FOREVER.
SO IN LIVING LIFE. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY HAVING TO LEARN TO
LET GO.
ALTHOUGH WE KNOW THIS TO BE TRUE.
I'VE COME TO FEEL THAT DE.
DEEP IN A LOVING PARENTS HARD.
THEY WILL NEVER LET GO.
IT WILL FOREVER BE WORRYING
ABOUT. CARING FOR AND LOVING
THEIR CHILDREN.
FOR SUCH IS THE NATURE OF OUR
PARENTS IMMEASURABLE LOVE.
HOWEVER OLD WE MAY BECOME.
THE BONDS OF LOVE BETWEEN PARENT
AND CHILD WILL REMAIN.
FOR THE OTHER BONDS OF LIFE
ITSELF.
THIS SUNDAY ESPECIALLY. MAKE
SURE YOU GIVE YOUR MOM A WARM
LOVING HUG.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
LOST OUR MINDS
LET US HOLD THEM CLOSE TO OUR
HEARTS.
WITH THIS IS STILL THEIR SPECIAL
DAY.
NUMBER ONE.
WITH GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS FOR
THE NURTURING KINDNESS OF OUR
LOVING MOTHERS.
THANK YOU REVEREND.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER ROBBERY.
READY BEGAN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
SOME OBSERVERS ARGUMENT ON
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE SUMMER BED
AT ONE PM BEYOND WILL COVER
MULLIN SPEAK WHAT EMPLOYEES
SIMPLY PRESIDE EQUIPE* IN A
DESPERATE CURRENTLY MOVES READ
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
COOLEY AND A FREE MAN.
AND FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OBERNOLTE
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND HIS
ARYAN.
SPEAK ON IN A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WERE BUILT
TO COMMITTEE. AS BEFORE FIFTY
NINE PORTANTINO FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM TO FORTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN RUBIO FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SO ME ONE NIGHT YOU KNOW SIX
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE TWENTY SIX
THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE ON NINE
TWENTY FIVE TWO NINE TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX OF THE
MINUTES TWENTY TWO NINETEEN OF
THE MINUTES. TWENTY TO THIRTY
WITH A MINUTES ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
ONE OF THE MINUTES THIRTY ONE
FIFTY SEVEN OF THE MINUTES
TWENTY SEVEN THREE THE MINUTES.
TWENTY SIX TIM AMENDED SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR
TO TWENTY FOURTH THIRTEEN.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT
TWENTY NIGHTS OF THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY. TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY THIRTY THIRTY THIRTY
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
SIXTY SEVENTY FORTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
NINETY NINETEEN THIRTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE OH
TO. TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TO FORTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX
TWENTY THREE NINETY SIX TWENTY
FOUR ELEVEN. POINT FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
TWENTY SUPPORT SIXTY EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX TWENTY NINE. POINT SIX
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY SIX NINETY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FOUR TWENTY
HAVE PICKED A THREE POINT SEVEN
SIXTY NINE POINT SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
NINE. TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
NINE FORTY ONE TWENTY NINE SIXTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE SEVEN THREE
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
NINE NINETY FOUR THIRTY TWELVE
THIRTY THIRTY TWO THIRTY ONE
TWENTY SIX THIRTY ONE FORTY
THREE THIRTY ONCE EVERY THREE
THIRTY ONE SEVEN SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. NINETY TWO. THIRTY TO
THIRTYONE THIRTY TWO THIRTY TO
THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE THIRTY TO
FIFTY EIGHT THIRTY TO SIXTY
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. POINT
THREE FIFTY THREE WITH A MINUTES
THIRTY TWO SEVENTEEN WITH OF ITS
NINETEEN FORTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY NINE I WITH
AMENDMENTS. SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX
SEVENTEEN NINETY TWO WITH A
MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THREE WITH.
ALL BILLS OF A RAT DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MEMBERS ON RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEMS NINETY THREE THROUGH
NINETY SEVEN. WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
TO TAKE UP.
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE
THE BODY TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE HUNDRED.
THIS IS AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
COOPERATE WITH AMENDMENTS ASSUME
ABLE TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
QUIRK.
DOCTOR QUIRK ON THE MINUTES.
I THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. THEY CHANGE A SHELL TO
A MAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAME.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED. THE BILL'S OUT TO
PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE A
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN.
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH BERMAN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FOR
THREE AMENDMENTS BY SIMPLY VERA
MEDINA.
MR MEDINA ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENT AMENDMENTS ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
THREE. THE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR
AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I GO.
AMOS MEDINA.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT TO BACK ON FILE
MEMBERS WE ARE WORKING THROUGH
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS. ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE WORK
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE ONE
THREE NINE.
THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COOPERATE WITH AMENDMENTS.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SIMILAR
MURATSUCHI.
MISTER MURATSUCHI ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTIES HE WILL
DECLARE SURFING AS CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICIALS STATE SPORT. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADDRESSING ADDING
THE HISTORICAL AND CULTURAL
CONTEXT AS TO WHY SURFING SHOULD
BE OUR PERSONAL SAY SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU S. MERCY HE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH I'D HAVE THE MEMBERS ARE
DOWN.
THE BILL IS OUT FRONT TO BACK
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL DOWN WE HAVE LOTS OF
BUSINESS FOR THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP A
COUPLE OF RESOLUTIONS.
BY MS LOW MOAN WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
TWO THAT'S EIGHT C. ARE ONE
SIXTY ONE.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO ACR ONE
SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSUMING CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY ONE BY SOME WOMEN
BELIEVE ARE RELATIVE TO THE
THIRTIETH ANNUAL STATE
SCIENTISTS A.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION AS LONG AS THE MONEY
THEY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB PERMISSION TO WEAR A PROP.
FOR THE PAST OUT OBJECTION THINK
YOU.
THAT FOR THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
STATE SCIENTISTS HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO SHOW THIRD THROUGH
SIXTH GRADE STUDENTS THE WORK
THAT REAL LIFE SCIENTISTS DO.
IN A HANDS ON AN EXCITING AND
FUN WAY.
V. EVENT TAKES PLACE ON THE WEST
STEPS OF THE STATE CAPITOL ON
STAYS SIGN TO STAY. AN
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED DATE TO
SET EACH YEAR BY A LEGISLATIVE
RESOLUTION THIS YEAR IT'S
THURSDAY MAY TENTH.
STAYING SCIENTISTS SAY IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS WHICH IS THE
EXCLUSIVE REPRESENTATIVE NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND SCIENTISTS
WORKING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
STAY SIGNED TO STAY CONTINUES TO
BE A WIDELY POPULAR EVENT DRYING
THREE THOUSAND PLUS ATTENDEES
EACH YEAR. THE ATTENDEES ARE
INVITED TO EXPLORE OVER FORTY
EXCITING HANDS ON EXHIBITS
INCLUDING FUND WITH CHEMISTRY.
REDUCE RECYCLE REUSE
WILDLIFE TRACKING OIL SPILL
CLEANUP FISHING IN THE CITY.
UNDERSTANDING EARTHQUAKES
FISH TAGGING AND MUCH MORE.
STATE SCIENTISTS ARE FOUND IN
THIRTY STATE DEPARTMENTS WORKING
IN MORE THAN EIGHTY ONE
SCIENTIFIC CLASSIFICATIONS.
THE PROBLEMS TACK THAT THEY
TACKLE ARE NUMEROUS.
CAN WE BUILD AN EFFECTIVE
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM HOW DO
WE DETERMINE ENERGY NEEDS FOR
THE COMING DECADE HOW TO REDUCE
SMOG AND TOXIC CHEMICALS IN OUR
AIR.
THESE ARE BUT A FEW OF THE
PROBLEMS CALIFORNIA SCIENTISTS
CONFRONT DAILY FINDING SOLUTIONS
REQUIRES ENERGY EDUCATED INSIGHT
AND DEDICATION. ON ANY GIVEN DAY
CALIFORNIA SCIENTISTS MAY BE HIP.
MAYBE ME DEEP AND CONTAMINATED
LAKE.
PROBING THE SECRETS OF BACTERIA
WITH AN ELECTRON MICROSCOPE OR
PROP POURING.
OVER AGING ARCHIVES TO DOCUMENT
THE HISTORY OF AN ENDANGERED
SPECIES THE WORK OF SAY
SCIENTISTS REQUIRE CRITICAL
DECISIONS WHICH ARE BASED ON
RIGOROUS SCIENTIFIC FACT FINDING
AND ULTIMATELY AFFECT THE LIVES.
AND PROPERTY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH THIS IN MIND PLEASE JOIN ME
IN ACKNOWLEDGING SCIENTISTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD BY AUTHORING ACR ONE SIXTY
ONE.
THANK YOU MS AMONG.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM IS THE
MOMENT YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON
THE RELEASE VERSION.
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE WILL WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
ONE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THIS IS
FOR HO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
HER CO AUTHORS MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
NOW MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO JUMP
TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TWO.
IS FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TWO ACR
TO TWENTY EIGHTS AGAIN BY MISS
LIMON THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO TWENTY EIGHT BY SOME WOMEN
REALLY NO RELATIVES CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES WILDFIRE AWARENESS
WEEK IN CALIFORNIA MASTER
MUTUALLY AWARENESS DAY.
MS AMONG YOU MAKE IT OPEN. THANK
YOU SPEAKERS AND MEMBERS.
ACR TO TWENTY EIGHT PROCLAIMS
THE WEEK OF MAY SIXTH THROUGH
TWELFTH AS CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
AWARENESS WEEK AND MAY SEVENTH
AS THE CALIFORNIA MASTER MUTUAL
AID AWARENESS STATE.
THIS RESOLUTION HONORS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ALL FIRST
RESPONDERS TO THE CATASTROPHIC
NATURAL DISASTERS TWENTY SET OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND RECOGNIZES
THE IMPACT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MUTUAL EIGHT DISASTER RESPONSE
SYSTEM. HAD IN REDUCING THE LOSS
OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE SEASON WAS ONE OF THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND DEVASTATING
YEARS ON RECORD.
ACROSS THE STATE ROUGHLY NINE
THOUSAND FIRES BURNED MORE THAN
ONE MILLION ACRES. AND TEN
THOUSAND STRUCTURES
WITH OVER SIXTY PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR LIVES TO THE WILD FIRES AS
WELL AS THE ENSUING DEBRIS FLOWS
THAT RESULTED.
THE DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY THE
NATURAL DISASTERS WILL BE FELT
IN MY OWN DISTRICT AS WELL AS
ACROSS THE STATE FOR DECADES TO
COME.
DESPITE THE LOSSES WE
EXPERIENCED IT IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
COURAGE SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION
OF ALL FIRST RESPONDERS AND THE
CRUCIAL ROLE THEY PLAYED IN
MINIMIZING THE DAMAGE. AND LOSS
OF LIFE.
WHILE FIRE FIGHTING IN THIS IS A
CENTRAL COMPONENT OF DISASTER
RESPONSE CALIFORNIA'S MUTUALLY
DISASTER RESPONSE SYSTEM RELIES
HEAVILY. UPON FIRST RESPONDERS
OF ALL FORMS.
AND JURISDICTIONS.
FROM EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PERSONNEL TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE FIREFIGHTERS THEMSELVES.
ACR TO TWENTY EIGHT RAISES
AWARENESS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
ORGANIZE AND COOPERATIVE
DISASTER RESPONSE AND FURTHER
MORE SEEKS TO HONOR THE BRAVERY
AND COMMITMENT OF ALL FIRST
RESPONDERS THAT MAKE UP
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID.
DISASTER RESPONSE SYSTEM.
I ASK THAT WE OPEN THE ROLE FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS LALONDE MISTER
LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SAY I'D JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA IN
SUPPORT OF ACR. TO TWENTY EIGHT
THIS SIDE THIS RESOLUTION IS A
REMINDER THAT WILD FIRES DON'T
HAPPEN FAR AWAY.
FROM US WILDFIRES HURT SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
CALIFORNIA WE SAW THIS PAST YEAR
THAT WILDFIRES HAPPEN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN AN ALMOST IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND TO DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES
OF LOSS OF LIFE LOSS OF PROPERTY
THAT WE SAW. AND I THOUGHT THAT
AFTER OCTOBER THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
THROUGH THE WORST OF IT BUT IT
WASN'T UNTIL DECEMBER WHERE
OTHER COMMUNITIES WERE
DEVASTATED BY THE WILDFIRES BUT
ALSO THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE
WILD FIRES LIKE THE MUD SLIDES.
IN MONTICELLO AND THAT WAS THEN
IN DECEMBER THAT FINALLY MY
FAMILY WAS TOUCHED BY IT WHEN MY
WIFE'S COUSIN LOST HER HOME. IN
VENTURA COUNTY.
THAT.
WAS ALL I ALSO CONTINUALLY AND
REMINDED BECAUSE I MYSELF LIVE
IN AWHILE THEN URBAN INTERFACE.
AND OFTEN ON RED FLAG WARNING
DAYS THERE IS A SIGN IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. BIG TO ALERT
PEOPLE THAT IT IS A RED FLAG DAY
AND TO BE VERY CAREFUL. AND THIS
IS SOMETHING WHEN WE HAVE A
RESOLUTION LIKE THIS TO REMIND
OURSELVES OF THE NEED TO INVEST
IN MUTUAL AID. AND THE NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR PRE POSITIONING FOR
OUR FORCES TO BE OUT THERE ON
RED FLAG DAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO FIGHT. WILDLAND
FIRES THANK YOU AND I ARE
TONIGHT THOUGH.
THEY MISS LEVINE MS AGUILAR
CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR TO TO A AND I APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM SEATS
SANTA BARBARA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I CAN'T BEGIN TO EXPRESS MY
DEEPEST HEARTFELT GRATITUDE FOR
THE FIRST RESPONDERS WHO RISKED
EVERYTHING TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES LAST FALL.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES NORTH AND SOUTH
RAVAGED COMMUNITIES BURNED DOWN
HOMES AND BUSINESSES AND TOOK
DOZENS OF LIVES.
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
STILL RECOVERING AND WILL BE
DOING THAT FOR A LONG TIME.
WELL WHILE WE TAKE THIS MOMENT
TO RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT
WILDFIRES I HOPE MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY COMMIT TO DO MORE. THAN BE
AWARE.
WE NEED ACTION WE NEED EVERYBODY
HERE TO BE AT THE TABLE WE MUST
DO ALL THAT WE CAN. TO REDUCE
THE RISK OF FOR A FUTURE
DISASTERS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
.
YOU CAN'T IMAGINE THE.
WHAT THE FIRST RESPONDERS WENT
THROUGH DURING THESE FIRES?
?
HAVING HAVING EXPERIENCED THIS
IN MY OWN DISTRICT WITH THE.
TUBS FIRE OF THE LOSS OF OVER
FIVE THOUSAND HOMES IN OVER TWO
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT.
THE THE AMAZING WORK OF THE OUR
MUTUAL AID PROGRAM THAT THAT
THAT HELPED US NOT JUST.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES
AND OTHER STATES.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE WE HAVE TO
DO MORE TO PREVENT THESE FIRES
WE HAVE TO DO MORE TO BE IN A
POSITION.
TO.
FIGHT THEM WHEN THEY WHEN WE
KNOW THEY'RE COMING.
THIS IS IN A IN REALLY
IMPORTANT AND REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I HOPE THAT WE
KNOW AS I AS MY AS OUR MEMBER
FROM WINTERS SAID.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN IN WAYS TO
PREVENT THIS AND I THINK WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE US THIS YEAR I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL CONSIDER THAT GOING
FORWARD. I THANK OUR ARE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR
BRING THIS FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OUR DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION
MISS THEM ON YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD.
Y. THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO ALL
OF CALIFORNIA AND SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND MEMBERS OF HIS A LOT IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS IS
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CARPOOL OPEN ROLL-ON.
RUMORS THIS IS FOR COAUTHORS
ADDING ONTO.
ACR TWO TWO EIGHT.
COAUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MISS AMAL BACK YOU
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU AT MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OUR GUESTS TODAY
I'M GOING TO
THEY STAND IN THE GALLERY. I'M
THESE ARE MEMBERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES FROM CAL FIRE FROM
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. AND THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING THEM
FOR THEIR COURAGE THEIR
SACRIFICE THEIR DEDICATION TO
BATTLING CALIFORNIA'S MORE
DESTRUCTIVE DISASTERS. THINK YOU
FOR ALL THAT YOU DO FOR
CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE.
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO HUNDRED.
ON THE ST THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED IS S. B..
EIGHT FORTY.
WILL BE TAKEN UP BY MR TANG.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW ACCOLADE TO THE BUDGET
ACT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
TING YOU MAIL BUT.
I THINK I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW US TO CREATE THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE PROCESS.
YOU SIMPLY ANTICIPATES ADOPTING
OUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET IN OUR
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING ON
MAY TWENTY NINTH.
ONCE THE SENATE NON CONCURS ON
THIS BILL THAT ALLOWS US TO
BEGIN THE CONFERENCE PROCESS
TENTATIVELY. ON MAY THIRTIETH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND AFTER PASSAGE I ASKED FOR
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER TING.
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THESE BUDGET SHALL
BILLS THIS IS THE ANNUAL GAME WE
PLAY EVERY YEAR THE ANNUAL SHELL
GAME THAT WE PLAY. WHERE WE?
LEAVE OUT THE POLICY PARTS WE
LEAVE OUT ALL THAT THE THE
THINGS THAT THE PUBLIC SHOULD
HAVE A RIGHT TO VIEW. AND WHEN
WE PHILLIP IN LATER ON THIS IS
NOT THE PROPER WAY TO DO A
BUDGET CERTAIN NOT THE PROPER
WAY TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO SEE
WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH THEIR
MONEY I THINK WE SHOULD ALLOW.
THAT ASSEMBLY.
THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THE SENATE'S.
TO PASS THEIR VERSION OF AT THE
BUDGET AND THEN COME CONFERENCE
TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN GO
THROUGH THIS WITH A FINE TO COME
AND SEE WHAT IS REALLY IN THERE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE.
I THINK YOU MISS MELENDEZ.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSED
HER DEBATE MISTER CHENEY MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
YEAH THANK YOU WITH WITH ALL ROB
RESPECT MY CALLING FROM LIKE
ELSINORE. THE BUDGET IS
COMPRISED OF THE VERY LENGTHY
DELIBERATION FROM EACH OF OUR
FIVE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES.
WHERE WE HAVE LIKE THE PUBLIC
DISCUSSION OVER EVERY ITEM OF
THE BUDGET WHETHER IT'S
EDUCATION? HEALTH CARE.
THE COURTS NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE HAVE ALMOST A HUNDRED
HEARINGS A YEAR HOURS AND HOURS
AND HOURS OF DELIBERATION OVER
EACH ITEM.
THE BILLS ARE JUST THE VEHICLES
THAT THE BUDGET WELL GO INTO THE
DELIBERATION HABITS IN THE WORK
HAPPENS FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND MONTHS AT EACH OF THE SUB
COMMITTEE LEVELS WHERE THE
PUBLIC HAS EVERY RIGHT AND DOES.
I ENGAGE IF YOU EVER SIGNED INTO
ANY THOSE SUBCOMMITTEE MEETINGS
THEY DO ENGAGE AT EVERY LEVEL
SOBRE THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THEY WERE STAYING AND WITHOUT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M.
TIRED OF THOUGH ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLIED ABOUT
EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY TWO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM ONE. FORTY SEVEN.
AND THIS IS ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN A. B..
EIGHTEEN OH SEVEN RECOVERY.
SOME PEOPLE EACH YOU KNOW SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
OTHERS AND I PLAYED TO THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
S. YOU'RE TELLING YOU MAKE AN
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ARE.
AB TWO NO SEVEN IS A BUDGET
BILL THAT WE ARE PASSING OVER TO
THE SENATE TO FACILITATE
ADOPTING THE FINAL BUDGET. THIS
BILL AND THIRTY NINE IDENTICAL
BILLS THAT FOLLOW WILL BE SENT
TO THE SENATE TO ALLOW US TO
VOTE ON THE BUDGET PACKAGE IN
BOTH HOUSES. ON THE SAME DAY.
THE SENATE HAS ALSO SENATE'S
FORTY BILLS FOR THIS PURPOSE AS
WELL.
I ASKED WE ARE ABOUT
.
THANK YOU MISTER TANG TO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LEVEL ROLL-ON VOTE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THAT OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES AND MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE ROLL CALL VOTE ON AB
EIGHTEEN OF SEVEN OH BE
SUBSTITUTED FOR THE VOTE ON
ITEMS ONE FORTY EIGHT THROUGH
ONE EIGHTY SIX.
HEARING NO OBJECTION THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SO ME TO EAT YOU KNOW A.
AYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY NINE EYES
FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ONE SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN TEN EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE SO WE REALLY TO
ELEVEN EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHTEEN TWELVE
EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN EYES
FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ONE SOME AGO.
EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE SO WE GO
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN EYES FIFTEEN
KNOWS TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE SO WE GO
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN. EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE SO WE WILL
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ONE EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ONE SO WE WILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWO EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY SOME WE WILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ONE SO WE WILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX SIZE FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY SEVEN. EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY TO TWENTY
EIGHT EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MORE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE EYES FIFTY KNOWS
TWENTY ONE SO WE WILL EIGHTEEN
THIRTY EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ONE. EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
ONE SO WE WILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
TWO EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
THREE EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
ONE SO WE WILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FOUR EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE. FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SIX SIZE FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY
EIGHT EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
SOME WE WILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
NINE EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY.
EYES FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE
EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY SO WE GO
EIGHTEEN FORTY TWO EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY SOME WE WILL
EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE EYES
FIFTEEN KNOWS TWENTY ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR EYES
FIFTEEN THOSE TWENTY ASSEMBLY
WILL EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE TIES
FIFTY NOSED. ANDERSON WE WILL
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO.
RETURN TO THE TOP OF THE THIRD
READING FILE.
THIS IS TOP OF ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT.
A. B..
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TO THE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN ACCOLADE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
IS RUBIO EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO A BILL WHICH WILL SET SAFE
TEMPERATURE STANDARDS FOR THE
MOBILE TIME TRANSPORTATION OF
DOGS AND CATS.
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS A PERSON
FROM LEAVING AN ANIMAL IN THE
UNATTENDED MORE VEHICLE UNDER
CONDITIONS OF ENDANGERED ANIMALS
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO LAW REQUIRING
THIEVES TEMPERATURE CONTROL
DURING THE TRANSPORTATION OF
THESE ANIMALS. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
BY ESTABLISHING YOU SAFE
TEMPERATURE STANDARDS FOR THE
MOBILE TRANSPORTATION OF DOGS
AND CATS TO ENSURE. THEIR
PROTECTION FROM TEMPERATURE
RELATED INJURIES OR DEATH.
THE BILL RECEIVED SOME
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND HAVE NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK OPEN ROLL-ON. WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE ON THEM WHICH VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN
A FILE ITEM NINETY NINE WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE A ONE ONE OF TWO AND
ONE OF THREE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE NO FOUR.
THAT IS A BE.
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY. BY MISTER.
COOPER.
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME IT WILL
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY BY SOME
REMEMBER COOPER AN ACOLYTE OF
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REMEMBERS IT BETWEEN NINE
SEVENTY WOULD SIMPLY CLARIFY
THAT NOTICE OF NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TO THE NEW EMPLOYEES MANAGEMENT.
THE REPRESENTATIVE AND VENDORS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ORIENTATION
IN ORDER TO INSURE. THE SAFETY
OF THOSE EMPLOYEES AND
MANAGEMENT.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED AB ONE
NINETEEN.
REQUIRED ALL THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES TO BE PROVIDED
ORIENTATION.
KEEP LOCATION DATE AND TIME
CONFIDENTIAL.
PREVENT ORGANIZATIONS FROM
ATTENDING NOR TO DISRUPT THE
ORIENTATION AS WELL AS ENSURING
EMPLOYEES PRIVACY AND SAFETY.
A RECENT REPORT BY THE US BUREAU
OF JUSTICE STATISTICS.
FOUND IT WORKPLACE VIOLENCE IS
THREE TIMES HIGHER.
THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
MOREOVER BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
PERCENT OF SECTOR WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE WAS DIRECTED AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR SECURITY OFFICERS.
GIVE THESE FACTS IS IMPERATIVE
WE PROTECT OUR NEW PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ATTENDING ORIENTATION
WHILE PROVIDING ADVANCE NOTICE
TO THE PERTINENT PARTIES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM THE CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
IS OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE OH FIVE THROUGH
ONE TEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE BY
MR CUNNINGHAM THE CORKERY.
SO WE WILL TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ACCOLADE COLLEGE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS.
YOUR CUNNINGHAM EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS.
THE COURSE OF THE YEAR THE
AVERAGE COLLEGE STUDENT
ACCORDING TO THE COLLEGE BOARD
SPENDS MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
ON TEXTBOOKS.
SPILLER JUST PUBLISHERS TO
PUBLISH A DETAILED DESCRIPTION
ON THE WEBSITE SHOWING HOW A NEW
EDITION OF A TEXTBOOK DIFFERS
FROM THE OLD ADDITION.
WHICH WILL HELP STUDENTS
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY NEED TO
SPEND THE MONEY ON A NEW
ADDITION.
WILL PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY HELP
CONTROL COSTS.
AND I WOULD KNOW THIS BILL IS A
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT BETWEEN A
CLASSIC CAL POLLY THAT IS TAUGHT
BY MY PREDECESSOR CULTURE
SERGEANT.
IT PASSED HIGHER ED COMMITTEE
WITH NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CARP LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. AND
HOW WE VOTE I SIXTY SIX.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE TWELVE PASS RETAIN
WE'VE DISPENSED OF FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN.
FILE ITEMS ONE FOURTEEN.
THROUGH ONE THE SEVENTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY
MISTER BERMAN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE TAXATION.
MISTER BERMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE A BILL TO MODERNIZE
THE TRANSMITTAL OF INFORMATION
BETWEEN ASSESSORS AND TAXPAYERS.
INCREASINGLY DOCUMENTS CAN BE
PROVIDED BY ASSESSORS AND
TAXPAYERS IN A MORE EFFICIENT
AND COST EFFECTIVE MANNER BY
MAIL AND IN SOME INSTANCES
ELECTRONICALLY. UNFORTUNATELY
EXISTING LAW IS WOEFULLY OUT OF
DATE.
AS A RESULT COUNTY ASSESSOR
STAFF MAY TRAVEL TO VARIOUS
LOCATIONS AROUND THE STATE TO
OBTAIN THE INFORMATION NECESSARY
TO DO THEIR JOB. EVEN THOUGH THE
INFORMATION COULD BE MAILED OR
PERHAPS TRANSMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY.
SIMILARLY WHY TAXPAYER NEEDS
INFORMATION FROM AN ASSESSOR
OFFICE
THE TAXPAYER TRAVELS TO AND MAY
HAVE TO WAIT IN LINE AT A COUNTY
OFFICE.
THIS BILL CREATES A RECIPROCAL
RIGHT OF AN ASSESSOR OR TAXPAYER
TO REQUEST THE INFORMATION BE
MAILED TO THEM OR SENT
ELECTRONICALLY IF AVAILABLE. MY
STAFF WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL TAKES A BALANCED
APPROACH PROVIDING BENEFITS TO
BOTH ASSESSORS. AND TAXPAYERS
ALIKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
NAMES BERMAN.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLLING TIED OF A NICE
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
ONE NINETEEN ONE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE PASS RETAIN.
MEMBERS WORD FILE ITEM. ONE
TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
OPERATE.
SO WE WILL TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR BY
SOME A MEMBER KALRA ACCOLADE
COURT REPORTERS IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SOME A BILL TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
REQUIRES ENTITIES PROVIDING
COURT REPORTING SERVICES TO
REGISTER WITH THE COURT REPORTER
IS BOARDING ORDER ACQUIRE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SAME LAWS.
AND REGULATIONS THAT DICTATE
FAIR AND NEUTRAL COURT REPORTING.
COURT REPORTING AS AN INTEGRAL
COMPONENT OF OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
IS THE ROLE OF THE BOARD TO
PROTECT ITS INTEGRITY BY MAKING
SURE ALL ENTITIES ARE PLAYING BY
THE SAME RULES.
THIS ASSURES CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED FROM ACTIONS THAT GIVE
ONE SIDE AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OR
PRACTICES THAT COMPROMISE THE
NEUTRAL CARE OF THE COURT
REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT.
CONTRARY TO OPPOSITION THE BOARD
AND LICENSE OWNED FIRMS CAN
ATTEST TO NUMEROUS ABUSES FROM
OUT OF STATE DEPOSITION FIRMS
THAT PROVIDE COURT REPORTING
SERVICES.
THESE ENTITIES USED LICENSE
COURT REPORTERS BUT IN THE
COURSE OF THEIR BUSINESS HAVE
DIRECT HANDLING OF THE
TRANSCRIPT IN A MANNER THAT
BREAKS COURT REPORTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
AS A TRIAL ATTORNEY THAT
PRACTICE FOR OVER ELEVEN YEARS I
CAN ATTEST THE FACT THAT IT'S
CRITICAL.
THE TRANSCRIPTS ARE.
HELD IN A WAY THAT.
FIRMS INTEGRITY AND THAT THERE'S
A CHAIN OF CUSTODY OF THEM THAT
CAN BE RELIED UPON BY ALL
PARTIES.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR CREATES A
LEGAL PATHWAY FOR THESE
UNREGULATED AT A STATE
DEPOSITION FIRMS TO DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT BRINGS PARITY
WITH OTHER SIMILAR COURT
REPORTER PROVIDERS. AND THE SAME
AT A STATE BERMS DOES STATES
REQUIRE IT OF FIRMS IN
CALIFORNIA
THIS IS TRULY ABOUT A BILL ABOUT
PARITY IN ENSURING. THE QUALITY
OF OF COURT REPORTING SERVICES
HAS A LEVEL INTEGRITY WE ALL
EXPECT EXPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FAMOUS COLLAR MS BAKER DIRECTOR
THAT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISING AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. AB
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR IS IDENTICAL
TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN I THINK RIGHTLY
SO IN HIS VETO MESSAGE HE
POINTED OUT THAT THIS VERY ISSUE
IS THE SUBJECT OF PENDING
LITIGATION. THAT LITIGATION
CONTINUES AND HAS NOT BEEN
RESOLVED AND WILL ADDRESS
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO
PASS THIS AND COMPLETELY HAVE TO
UNRAVEL. OF TREMENDOUSLY
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS WE PUT
ON.
CERTAIN SERVICE COMPANIES TO
OPERATE IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE I AM AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE HIS BODY TO
CONTINUE THE TRADITION OF NOT
INTERFERING WITH PENDING
LITIGATION.
PICKING ONE FAVORED OVER THE
OTHER ALLOW THAT PROCESS IN A CO
EQUAL BRANCH TO WORK ITSELF OUT
AND THEN WE CAN ALWAYS BE
RESPONSIVE AS NECESSARY IF WE
DISAGREE WITH THE OUTCOME OF
THAT COURT. RULING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THING IS BAKER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. MISTER KALRA
YOU MAY CLOSE VIEW WHICH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST
OF ALL OF THIS IS NOT REQUIRE
ANYTHING OVER THE BURDENSOME
REQUIRES THE EXACT SAME THING
THAT OUR CALIFORNIA FIRMS HAVE
TO ABIDE BY. SECONDLY IN TERMS
LITIGATION OF THE LITIGATION IS
NOT RELEVANT TO THIS BILL NO
MATTER WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THE
LITIGATION. THIS BILL WOULD
STILL BE NECESSARY I AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT WE DID
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS PRIOR
TO THE VETO LAST YEAR IT IS A
BILL THAT OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST
YEAR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
SAME OF OF MEMBERS THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
THINGS KALRA WITHOUT CORP WILL
ROLL-ON.
SORRY TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
WELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY ONE.
KNOWS TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN.
COOPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
EGGMAN THAT ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH ADVOCACY.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER THIS BILL SIMPLY JUST
REQUIRES A STATE DEPARTMENT
HOSPITALS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING MANUAL
FOR.
SERVING AS ADVOCATES FOR OF FOR
THE MENTALLY ILL AND ME
AVAILABLE STATEWIDE FOR FOLKS
WHO DON'T ALREADY HAVE ACCESS
IMPORTANT ROLE PROVIDES THEM
ACCESS TO THE TRAINING THEY
DESPERATELY NEED. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SELECT RAYMOND SENIOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELLING THE VOTE
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY FOUR AND ONE TWENTY FIVE
HOUSE RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
SIX COOPERATE?
SO WE WILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX
WISELY MEMBER WOULD WANNA GO SEE
ANOTHER SIGN THAT RELATE TO BE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN THINK MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
IS A PROCEDURE MEASURE THAT
WOULD CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE FUND.
INTO WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL MAY DEPOSIT
MONEY TO PROVIDE.
SUPPORT FOR NEWLY CREATED BUREAU
OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
YOU DIG YOUR OLD MISSION IS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT IN VERY DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION.
TO INVESTIGATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF VIOLATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
NOW I'VE HEARD A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS THAT THEY BELIEVE FOR.
THESE REMARKS.
ARAB. CLARIFY THOSE CONCERNS.
AND THAT IS THAT THE BILL WOULD
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO EXPAND
LITIGATION OR SEEK.
EXCESSIVE PENALTIES TO FUND THE
WORK.
BUREAU.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
FUNDS ALREADY ESTABLISHED
THAT THAT COLLECT SETTLEMENTS OF
PENALTIES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
OBVIATES WORK AND THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT THE PRESENCE OF
THESE FUNDS OR THE USE OF THE
SETTLEMENT REVENUES
TO FUND THE WORK HAS. INDUCED
EXCESSIVE LITIGATION FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AT WITHOUT THEM ESTABLISHING AND
SUPPORTING THE WORK OF THE DAY
BUREAU. A WE'RE TAKING THE FIRST
STEP TOWARDS ASSISTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES WOULD OTHERWISE
SUFFER POOR HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES THAT ARE MORE MUCH MORE
COSTLY TO THE STATE IF LEFT.
ON ADDRESS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
THEY WAS GARCIA MISS RATES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX
AS A PROUD A JOINT AUTHOR AND.
JUSTICE ADVOCATE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
SUCH AS MINE AND MY COLLEAGUE.
SOME COACHELLA SUFFER FROM THE
UNDUE BURDEN OF POLLUTION DUE TO
ISSUES SUCH AS TOPOGRAPHY AND
HISTORIC CULTURE OF NEGLECT.
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
YET PLACENTA ANNOUNCED THE
CREATION OF THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
THIS WAS A CRITICAL STEP FOR THE
EDA MOVEMENT AND CEMENTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S ROLE. IN
FOCUSING ON INVESTIGATING AND
LITIGATING ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS
IN OUR MOST DISENFRANCHISED AND
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE AS A STAY
PRIORITIZE STANDING UP. FOR
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL BEFORE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY FOR
EVERYONE AND ASSURING THAT YOUR
ZIP CODE DOES NOT DICTATE YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE CLEAN AIR TO
BREATHE. AND CLEAN WATER TO
DRINK.
BY CREATING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE FUND WITHIN THE STATE
TREASURY WE'RE PROVIDING THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WITH ANOTHER TOOL TO HELP
PROTECT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTRESS SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
MISTER CA MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL CLICK
LIBERAL. I'M.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE ICE
FORTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
DOCTOR QUIRK THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER QUIRK
ACCOLADES CANNABIS.
QUIRK EMAIL AND.
BOB THANK YOU SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE REMOVES AMBIGUITY REGARDING
CANNABIS TESTING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CANNABIS
TESTING LABORATORIES CAN ACCEPT
SAMPLES FROM EITHER A LICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESS.
OR A MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT
OR CAREGIVER WHO GROWS PLANTS
FOR THEIR PERSONAL USE.
HOWEVER THE LAW IS UNCLEAR AS TO
WHETHER CANNABIS TESTING
LABORATORIES CAN ACCEPT SAMPLES.
FROM PEOPLE WHO GROW.
FOR PERSONAL USE ONLY.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
RENDON THESE THIS AMBIGUITY BY
CLEARLY PERMITTING CANNABIS
TESTING LABS.
TO ACCEPT SAMPLES FROM PEOPLE
WHO GROW CANNABIS FOR THEIR
PERSONAL USE.
FURTHER.
SIMILAR TO MEDICAL CANNABIS
REGULATIONS THESE TESTED SAMPLES
WOULD NOT BE CERTIFIED FOR
RESELLER TRANSFER.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE IS
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIHRI VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
SEEING NOTICE IT MISTER DALLI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SIR SPEAKER.
A QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
DO THEY HAVE TO PAY THE FEE DE
TO TEST THEIR OWN CANNABIS OR IS
IT SOMETHING THAT THE STATE WILL
BE PAYING.
YEAH BILL PAY THEM AROUND FOR ME
ABSOLUTELY.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE AYE SIXTY ONE.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE TWENTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE.
A. B. THIRTY THIRTY FOUR.
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
CLERK READ.
SO WE WILL THIRTY THIRTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER
BAKER. MS BAKER ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM CUPERTINO FOR
BRINGING THE UNDERLYING MEASURE
AB THIRTY THIRTY FOUR FORWARD.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER THIS
SET OF AMENDMENTS TO ENHANCE
WHAT I THINK IS THE RIGHT GOAL
WHICH IS TO REDUCE LABOR STRIFE
AYE WITHIN THE BART SYSTEM IN
THE BAY AREA. AND TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S LESS LIKELY IN THE FUTURE
THAT WE RELIVE THE STRIKES THAT
HAVE PLAGUED THE BAY AREA IN THE
PAST I KNOW THE AUTHORS. A VERY
WELL WRITTEN ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL MENTIONS THAT THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN BART STRIKES
THERE WERE TWO OF THEM WERE AN
INSPIRATION FOR THIS SPELL. AND
I BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS AND WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO STE TO HAVE THE FULL
POTENTIAL OF THE BILL REACHED.
BART IS A MAJOR COMPONENT OF BAY
AREA TRANSPORTATION OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE A DAY RELY ON BART TO GET
TO WORK SEE THEIR DOCTOR GET TO
SCHOOL ENGAGING LIFE IN THE BAY
AREA. AND EVERY DAY WRITERS COME
FROM ALL OVER THE BAY AREA NORTH.
EAST SOUTH.
AND BART IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
TO BAY AREA MOBILITY AND I THINK
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WITHOUT BART WORKER SHOWING UP
TO DO THEIR JOBS AND CONTINUING
TO ENSURE THAT PART HAS
CONTINUOUS UNINTERRUPTED SERVICE
PART IS NOT THE LIFE LINE IT
NEEDS TO BE FOR THE BAY AREA.
NOW IS OUR.
GOOD COLLEGE IN CUPERTINO HAS
MENTIONED IN HIS WRITTEN SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THE INSPIRATION FOR
THE UNDERLYING BILL IS TO
PREVENT FUTURE BART STRIKES.
EVERYONE IN THE BAY AREA GOT A
TERRIBLE REMINDER OF THE NEED TO
DO THAT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN
THE STRIKES CAME FORWARD. AND IT
BROUGHT THE ENTIRE BAY AREA TO A
GRINDING HALT WE LOST SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS A DAY. IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FROM BART
STRIKES EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
MORE CARS REPORT ON THE ROADS AS
ARE AIRIES ROADS FREEWAYS AND
OTHER SYSTEMS WERE. COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED SIXTEEN MILLION
POUNDS OF CARBON WERE RELEASED
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT ON A DAILY
BASIS FROM THE BART STRIKES.
AND.
THE UNDERLYING BILL DOESN'T
PREVENT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE STRIKES TO HAPPEN IN THE
WAY THAT WE ARE OFTEN CONFRONTED
WITH AND THAT'S THIS.
BART WORKERS ALREADY AGREED IN
THEIR CONTRACT NOT TO STRIKE.
THEY HAVE A NO STRIKE CLAUSE.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE NEGOTIATIONS
GO FORWARD AND THE CONTRACT
EXPIRES?
DURING THAT EXPIRATION PERIOD
BART CONTINUES TO PAY THEIR
WORKERS THEIR WAGES HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR ENTIRE FAMILY AND THEIR
PENSION BENEFITS.
BUT BART DOES NOT BELIEVE OF
THE BART WORKERS DON'T BELIEVE
THEY HAVE TO HONOR THE NO STRIKE
CLAUSE. DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS
SO THE CONTRACTS EXPIRED THEY
DON'T THINK THEY HAVE TO HONOR
THE NO STRIKE BECAUSE BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO BE PAID UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE CONTRACT THAT
THEY SAY HAS EXPIRED. THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
TODAY FIXES THAT IN A WAY THAT
IS FAIR TO BOTH THE WRITERS AND
THE WORKERS. IT SAYS ONLY THIS
IF YOU'RE PART UNION HAS ALREADY
AGREED NOT TO STRIKE.
IT DOESN'T IMPOSE A NO STRIKE
CLAUSE ON THEM IT'S ONE THAT
THEY AGREED TO AND THEY CONTINUE
TO BE PAID. AFTER THE CONTRACT
HAS EXPIRED THEY CONTINUE TO GET
THE BENEFITS OF THAT CONTRACT
THEY HAVE TO HONOR THE NO STRIKE
CLAUSE THE NEGOTIATED. THAT IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO CONTINUE
SERVICE AT PART AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE LABOR MANAGEMENT STRIFE
THAT OUT BECAUSE THE STRIKES IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN ARE NOT REPEATED
AGAIN. WITH GREAT GREAT RESPECT
FOR COLLEGE IN CUPERTINO IS
BRINGING FORWARD THE RIGHT ISSUE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR THESE MOMENTS.
THANK YOU THIS BAKER MISTER
CALDERON.
MOVED TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE MISTER CALDERON MOVES
A LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
SECONDED BY MISTER BONTA MEMBERS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON LAINEY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND MS.
BAKER'S ASKING FOR NO MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TAKES MAJORITY PRESENT AND
VOTING.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY TO
THE AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER SET OF
AMENDMENTS
ON THIS ITEM.
CORKERY.
SO ME PROPERLY THIRTY FORMER THE
MINUTES BY SOME THE RIVER BAKER.
IS BAKER ON THE MINUTES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THESE
AMENDMENTS AND OFFER THEM AGAIN
TO ENHANCE OF THE STATED GOAL OF
THE UNDERLYING LEGISLATION WHICH
AGAIN IS A VERY GOOD GOAL AND I
APPRECIATE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
CUPERTINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND THAT IS TO ADDRESS
A CIRCUMSTANCE THAT ALSO
CONTINUES TO CAUSE LABOR
MANAGEMENT STRIFE WITHIN PART.
AND TO HEIGHTEN THE A LIKELIHOOD
OF A STRIKE AND THE DISRUPTION
FROM THE STRIKE UNDER CURRENT
LAW AND CONTRACTS.
BART MANAGEMENT IS PROHIBITED.
FROM TAKING ANY ACTION TO
PREPARE FOR AN IMMINENT STRIKE
UNTIL THE STRIKE HAS HAPPENED
AND WORK HAS STOPPED THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO TRAIN THEMSELVES TO
OPERATE THE TRAINS THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO. A MAKE PREPARATIONS TO
HAVE A SKELETAL A TRAIN SYSTEM
OPERATIONAL AND CREW AVAILABLE
NOT ONLY FOR MOST BASIC AND
SKELETAL OPERATIONS BUT FOR
SAFETY. I'M WITH THIS MAJOR DOES
IS IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT THAT PART
CAN ENTER NO CONTRACT. IN THE
FUTURE WHICH WILL PREVENT THEM
FROM BEING ABLE TO PLAN FOR A
WORK STOPPAGE BEFORE IT HAPPENS
IMPOSING UPON BAY AREA RESIDENTS
I NEED THAT A STRIKE HOUSE TO
START. BEFORE ANYONE CAN LIFT A
FINGER TO TRY TO AMELIORATE OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE WAY IT
AFFECTS PEOPLE'S LIVES A IS THE
NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO GO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THESE MOMENTS.
CALDERON FOR A PURPOSE MOVED TO
LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLES
CALDERON MOVES LADY MEMBERS ON
TABLE THE SECOND BY MISTER BONTA
MEMBERS AGAIN A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING. ON
LAINEY MEMBERS ON THE TABLE
CLERK WILL OPEN ALL.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MS BAKER NOW IS CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR MY VOTE.
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR DIMAS
BAKER'S ASKING FOR NO.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
TWENTY ONE. THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE
LAID ON THE TABLE.
NOW TO THE BILL AND CHIEF THIS
IS AB THIRTY THIRTY FOUR BY MR
LOW CORKERY.
SO WE WILL THIRTY THIRTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER LOW AND ACT LIKE
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
MR LOW EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D WHILE I DO
NOT APPRECIATE THESE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL IN CHIEF. OF
THIS BILL GIVES THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
JURISDICTION OVER LABOR DISPUTES
FOR THE SUPER ZORI UNIT OF PART.
BY MOVING EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS FOR THE SUPERVISORY
UNITS ARE WE TALKED AND HEARD
ABOUT THE LABOR DISPUTES AT THAT
HAVE OCCURRED AT THIS BILL WILL
HELP THOSE LABOR DISPUTES.
IN CHIEF AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOVE MS BAKER
YOUR RECORD NEXT THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO.
THIRTY THIRTYFOUR AND ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTES AND AGAIN THAT THE
BILL ABSOLUTELY HAS THE RIGHT
GOAL WHICH IS TO REDUCE. US
STRIFE BETWEEN MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR AT PART HAVE MORE HOPE
HARMONIOUS WAY HAVE.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP AND ALSO
ULTIMATELY TO PREVENT PREVENT
FUTURE WORK STOPPAGES
UNFORTUNATELY I'M I I BELIEVE.
THAT THE BILL CAN AND WILL HAVE
THE OPPOSITE EFFECT AND HERE IS
HOW. I AM RIGHT NOW BAR IS
GOVERNED BY THE PART ACT
WHICH SPECIFIES HOW LABOR
DISPUTES INCLUDING MID CONTRACT
DISPUTES WILL BE RESOLVED WE ARE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CONTRACT PERIOD WITH PART. OF
THEIR CONTRACTS RENEWED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY DON'T EXPIRE
UNTIL I BELIEVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT NEEDS TO RESOLVE THEY
HAVE DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT.
MAYBE HOW WORKERS ARE
CLASSIFIED A WHAT OURS WILL BE
APPLIED.
WHAT PROVISIONS MAY BE
NECESSARY FOR TRAINING?
UNDER THE BARD ACTS.
WORK CONTINUES BART CONTINUES TO
OPERATE THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY OF THE QUESTIONS
REMAINING BETWEEN MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR CONTINUE TO BE A RESOLVED.
UNTIL THE NEGOTIATIONS RESOLVE
IT THAT MEANS THERE ISN'T A WORK
STOPPAGE IF WE PASS THIS BILL.
AND PER HERB IS THE ENTITY THAT
IT OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WILL
GOVERN THIS PARTICULAR UNIT
THERE CAN AND WILL BE WORK
STOPPAGES AND PROBABLY THE BEST
WAY FOR ME TO.
EXPLAIN THAT IS BY
DEMONSTRATION SO CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW PARTISAN TO GOING A SEISMIC
SAFETY RETROFIT OF THE TRANSBAY
TO. THIS IS THE ONE CONNECTION
BETWEEN BART ACROSS THE BAY AREA.
IT'S CRITICAL AND IT IS A
BOTTLENECK
THERE ARE NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT THAT NEED
TO OCCUR RELATED TO THE WORK
THAT WILL BE DONE ON THAT
SEISMIC RETROFIT. THE INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT HOURS BART WILL
BE SHUT DOWN IT'S CALLED THE
BLANKET THE HOURS OF NO
OPERATION FOR WORKERS TO GO
THROUGH AND DO THE WORK. IT ALSO
INCLUDES WHO WILL BE CATEGORIZED
AS SAFETY SENSITIVE POSITIONS
AND A FEDERAL LAW WILL APPLY.
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT NEED TO WORK OUT
UNDER EXISTING LAW THEY CAN WORK
THEM OUT WHILE THE SAFETY
RETROFIT OF THE TRANSBAY TO
WHICH IS CRITICAL. CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD IF THIS BILL PASSES.
THAT WORK WILL STOP BECAUSE A
NEW FACT FINDING PROCESS WILL
NEED TO BEGIN BEFORE ANY FURTHER
WORK CAN CONTINUE AND THAT
PROCESS WHILE TECHNICALLY ON THE
BOOKS IS SUPPOSED TO LAST FOR
SEVERAL DAYS. CAN LAST TYPICALLY
THREE TO SIX MONTHS THAT MEANS
TRANSBAY TUBE SAFETY WORK WILL
NOT HAPPEN.
BART WILL BE DELAYED IN DOING
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS AS A RESULT
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
GIVE A SECOND EXAMPLE.
CRITICAL TO BART HAVING OF THE.
GREATEST CAPACITY THAT IT NEEDS
I THINK ALL BAY AREA RESIDENTS
REALIZE PART NEEDS GREATER
CAPACITY THEY'RE GETTING A LOT
OF NEW TRAINS ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NEW TRAINS THESE TRAINS
HAVE COMPUTERIZED.
MONITORING AND TRAIN CONTROL
SYSTEMS THAT WILL BE PART OF
THEM.
IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW
COMPUTERIZED TRAIN CONTROL
SYSTEM REQUIRES NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN LABOR AND MANAGEMENT
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE WILL BE TRAINED
WHO WILL OWN.
OPERATE AT THE NEW CONTROL
CENTERS WHAT WILL THE WORK
CONDITIONS BE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS CAN BE WORKED
OUT WITH LESS STRIFE WHILE THE
WORK CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRAIN MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS UNDER
THIS BILL THE WORK WILL STOP.
AND THAT MEANS THAT BART WILL
NOT HAVE THE FULL CAPACITY IT IS
TRYING TO GET FROM THE NEW
TRAINS THAT THIS BODY IS PUTTING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO.
THEN NEEDED CAPACITY ACROSS THE
TRANSBAY TUBE WHICH IS SUPPOSED
TO INCREASE BY THIRTY PERCENT IF
THESE TRAIN CONTROL SYSTEMS ARE
PUT INTO PLACE WILL NOT HAPPEN
THIRTY SECONDS OR SO.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED TO LEAVE
EXISTING LAW THE WAY IT IS.
BECAUSE WE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
CREATE STRIFE AND LABOR
STOPPAGES INSTEAD OF THE WORK
CONTINUES AND FINALLY THERE ARE
FIVE. UNIONS RELATED TO BART
THIS PROVISION WILL ONLY APPLY
TO ONE OF THEM THE SMALLEST
UNION SO THAT WHEN WE COME TO A
CONTRACT.
EXPIRATION PERIOD WILL HAVE
DIFFERENT RULES FOR HOW
CONTINUING LABOR NEGOTIATIONS
HAVE TO GO FORWARD. WILL IT STOP.
ALL MANNER OF NEGOTIATIONS AND
WORK WELL THERE'S A STRIKE OR
WILL YOU CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE WORK. THESE ARE
PROVISIONS THAT I THINK ARE
CRITICAL TO QUALITY OF LIFE IN
THE BAY AREA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU KNOW VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO CLARIFY
SOME THINGS I HEARD BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE CONFUSING
WHEN PEOPLE START TALKING ABOUT
WORK STOPPAGES.
ANY TIME WORKERS ARE UNDER A
CONTRACT THEY CANNOT STRIKE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THERE
SUBJECT TO THE P. YOU SEE IS A
PART WORKERS ARE CURRENTLY AND
HAVE TO TAKE ANY MATTERS TO
COURT OR IF THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
PER.
WHAT PROOF DOES IS ACTUALLY DE
ESCALATE ISSUES BETWEEN
MANAGEMENT LABOR BY WORKING IT
OUT AND IT'S TOUGH IT AT?
TRIED WAY AWAY THAT ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ARE A VAST MAJORITY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY HAVE
TO WORK OUT DISPUTES.
IT TO SUGGEST THAT IF THERE ARE
SAFETY REGULATIONS MOVING
FORWARD AND THE UNION
REPRESENTING THE WORKERS THINK
THAT MAYBE THERE OUR REGULATIONS
THAT NEED BE IT HERE TO TO KEEP
THOSE WORKER SAFE. THAT THE WAY
TO WORK IT OUT IS TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT WORK IN AN UNSAFE WAY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEN THE WORK
GETS DONE. AYE I WOULD QUESTION
WHETHER THAT'S A GOOD APPROACH
THAT ANY UNION OR ANY A.
FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
BOTH WORKERS AND THE WORK
GETTING DONE SHOULD WANT
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE ALL IT DOES IS
TAKE PART THIS PART BART.
BARGAINING UNIT AND TAKE IT OUT
OF THE P. YOU SEE WHICH IS AN
INAPPROPRIATE PLACE TO HANDLE
ANY KIND OF LABOR RELATIONS IT
ACTUALLY PUSHES IT TO COURT.
AND IT MOVES IT SUPERB WHICH A
MAJORITY OF OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
OUR RD UNDER YOU DON'T SEE
MASSIVE WORK STOPPAGES HAPPENING
IN THE MIDDLE OF A CONTRACT
BECAUSE IT CAN'T HAPPEN IN THE
MIDDLE THE CONTRACT. PERV
INSURES THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE CONTRACT
WILL THEY STOP WORK IF THERE IS
A A DISPUTE OVER WHAT THE
CONTRACT SAYS WELL THEY SAY THAT
YOU CAN'T GO ON. AHEAD WITH
UNSAFE WORK CONDITIONS YEAH THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN AND THAT MIGHT BE A
GOOD THING FOR ALL OF US SOMEONE
BE CLEAR WHEN I'M THE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FROM THE EAST BAY
WAS HOW ABOUT WORK STOPPAGES
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT STRIKES
STATS ILLEGAL. WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONTRACT IN PLACE IN THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
BARGAINING UNITS THAT MAYBE
UNDER DIFFERENT FORMS THAT'S
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE FACE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PLACES AND SO I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S. ABOUT
ARGUMENT VOTE THIS BILL DOWN
THIS MAKES SENSE IT'S GOOD FOR
THE WORKERS ENHANCE ACTUALLY
GOOD FOR THE MANAGEMENT AS WELL.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS EIGHT IS
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR MOST
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY.
MISTER LOW YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I JUST A
FUNDAMENTALLY OF THE RIGHT TO
STRIKE IS OF FUNDAMENTAL LABOR
PROTECTION AND THE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS WOULD HAVE OUTLAWED
OF SUCH AN ACT.
THIS IS ALSO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE OF PRECEDENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE THE
LEGISLATURE TRANSFERRED
JURISDICTION OF.
SUCH LABOR DISPUTES REGARDING
THIS SUPERVISORS BARGAINING
UNITS AT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY PHILIP YOU SEE TO
PROBE AND ASSEMBLY BILL THEN OUT
ONE NINETY NINE SO THERE IS
PRECEDENT FOR THIS. AND THIS IS
A REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE A TO
ENSURING THAT THERE IS NOT THIS
LABOR STRIFE THAT WE SEE IN THIS
AREA I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT
VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS LOW AND WITHOUT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS BETTER DECIDE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY FIVE NEWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY. AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE MR FRAZIER THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSUMING WILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME BIGGER FRAZIER
ACCOLADE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
FRAZIER YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MIGHT BILL TODAY'S VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE AUTHORIZES THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY.
A CONTRACT WITH THE CHP FOR
SECURITY SERVICES HAVE PROPERTY
PURCHASED BY THE STATE FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL RIGHT OF WAY.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ADEQUATE GLOBAL ROLL-ON. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE. TALLY VOTE ICE FORTY
EIGHT NEW SIXTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE.
IS AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
ACCOLADE PARENTAGE.
BLOOM EMAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I AM PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH UPDATES THE UNIFORM
PARENTAGE ACT.
THE EPA WAS ADOPTED THAT BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO
ELIMINATE.
SCREAMING OF TORY TREATMENT OF
NON MARITAL CHILDREN.
TWO YEARS AGO THE UNIFORM LAW
COMMISSION A NON PARTISAN
ADVISORY GROUP AUTHORIZED A
REVISION OF THE EPA. TO ENSURE
EQUAL PROTECTION FOR CHILDREN OF
SAME SEX COUPLES.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
INCORPORATES CHANGES FROM THOSE
VERY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL EXPANDS
THE ADMINISTRATIVE VOLUNTARY
DECLARATION OF PARENTAGE
PROCEDURES.
TO INCLUDE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
USED.
ASSISTED REPRODUCTION ENABLING
PARENTS TO HAVE THE LEGAL
DETERMINATION OF PARENTAGE THAT
ENTITLES THEM TO RECOGNITION IN
OTHER STATES WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO TO COURT.
AND ALSO UPDATES PROVISIONS
REGARDING GENETIC TESTING TO
APPLY EQUALLY TO MEN AND WOMEN.
AND REQUIRES SPERM BANKS AND
FERTILITY CENTERS TO ASK IF
DONORS WOULD LIKE TO DISCLOSE
THEIR IDENTITY OR NON
IDENTIFYING MEDICAL HISTORY
INFORMATION WHICH IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS IT WOULD ALLOW
CHILDREN. EIGHTEEN YEARS OR
OLDER TO OBTAIN THEIR GENETIC
MEDICAL HISTORY.
OUR THIS BILL UPDATES THE FAMILY
LAW CODE TO REFLECT CURRENT LAW
AND TECHNOLOGY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVA.
NAMES BLOW SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LIBERAL. I'M VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE UNTIE THE VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY TWO WHERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE THAT IS
AB THIRTY FORTY TWO BY MISTER
SANTIAGO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO ME WILL THIRTY FORTY TO BUY
SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL HOLIDAYS.
FOR SANTIAGO YOU MAY OPEN
VIGOROUS SPEAKER A. B. THIRTY
FORTY TWO WOULD PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
COMBINED TO PRESIDENT DAY
HOLIDAYS INTO ONE HOLIDAY. THEN
DESIGNATE MAY FIRST OF
INTERNATIONAL WORKERS DAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
YES MISS MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE TO
ISSUES AT HAND HERE WITH THIS
BILL ONE IS THE ISSUE. OF THE
NEW HOLIDAY INTERNATIONAL
WORKERS DAY.
AND THE OTHER OF COMBINING DAYS
THAT WE TAKE.
SET ASIDE EACH YEAR TO RECOGNIZE
TWO VERY IMPORTANT PRESIDENTS IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
NOW WE ALREADY HAVE A DAY WHERE
WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF.
THE LABOR MOVEMENT RIGHT IT'S
CALLED LABOR DAY.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT.
OF LABOR DAY LABOR DAY CAME
ABOUT
SHORTLY AFTER FACT IN THE SAME
YEAR. THAT THE PULLMAN STRIKE
WAS TAKING PLACE.
AND DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT GROVER
CLEVELAND DECIDED TO SEND IN
TWELVE THIRTEEN THOUSAND TROOPS.
TO BREAK UP TO STRIKE TWO
WORKERS WERE KILLED THERE WAS
SUCH A PUBLIC OUTCRY.
THAT WE THEN HAD LABOR DAY.
A DAY THAT IS SET ASIDE TO
RECOGNIZE THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS.
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE GOOD
WORKING CONDITIONS FARE OURS FOR
WAGES FOR PAY. THAT IS ALL
ENCOMPASSED IN LABOR DAY.
WE HAVE TWO DAYS A YEAR WHERE WE
RECOGNIZE.
TWO VERY IMPORTANT PRESIDENT'S
OUR NATION'S HISTORY VERY
SPECIFICALLY THOUGH. REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT LINCOLN.
WHO WERE IT NOT FOR HIM IN HIS
LEADERSHIP?
ABOUT SLAVERY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABOLISHED.
SO YOU'RE GONNA TAKE A DAY.
THAT IS SET ASIDE WITHIN OUR
SCHOOLS EDUCATION SYSTEM WITHIN
THEIR CURRICULUM WHERE TEACHERS
ARE SUPPOSED TO DISCUSS.
THE CONTRIBUTION TO PRESIDENT
LINCOLN THE GROUNDWORK HE LAID.
FOR THIS COUNTRY TO EXIST AS IT
DOES TODAY WITH THE RIGHTS AND
FREEDOMS OF ALL.
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE THAT DAY IN
COMBINATORICS ANOTHER DAY.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE PRESIDENT
DURING TAKE TWO VERY IMPORTANT
PRESIDENTS TO OUR HISTORY
PUTTING INTO ONE DAY.
AND CREATE TWO DAYS.
TWO HOLIDAYS FOR THE LABOR
MOVEMENT.
NOW I WILL REMIND YOU WERE IT
NOT FOR PRESIDENT LINCOLN THEIR
WOULD BE NO LABOR MOVEMENT THERE
WOULD BE NO LABOR DAY.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
BRINGING FORWARD A BILL THAT
DIMINISHES THE INCREDIBLE
IMPORTANCE A CONTRIBUTION.
A PRESIDENT LINCOLN TO THIS
COUNTRY VERY SPECIFICALLY.
TO THE HISTORY OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
WHY IS THIS WHY ARE WE STARTING
TO WATER DOWN HISTORY?
WATER DOWN HISTORY.
OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AND REPLACE IT WITH THE LABOR
DAY.
ANOTHER LABOR DAY HOLIDAY I
THINK THAT DOES A DISSERVICE TO
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
SPECIFICALLY.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAPPEN TO
BE AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO NEED TO
LEARN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED. AS
THOSE EVER READ BY MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
THEY MOST CERTAINLY NEED TO HEAR
THIS BEING TAUGHT THE CLASS WAS
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU RECOMBINE THE TWO.
YOU GET A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WASHINGTON DID YOU GET A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT LINCOLN DEAD.
BUT YOU GET TWO DAYS OF THE
LABOR MEN AND I WOULD ARGUE.
THAT THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
LINCOLN.
AND WASHINGTON.
CERTAINLY DESERVE THEIR OWN DAY
DURING THE YEAR. IN OUR SCHOOLS
EDUCATION SYSTEM SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK YOU KNOW VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I AM AGHAST.
IT DID BILL LIKE THIS TO BE ABLE
TO GET THROUGH COMMITTEE.
GRANTED IT'S CALIFORNIA.
SERIOUSLY.
SUBSTITUTION.
OF ADDING.
INTERNATIONAL SOCIALIST WORKER'S
DAY.
MAYDAY.
THE DAY A PARADES IN THE SOVIET
UNION THAT ALL WE ALL GROW UP
WITH WITH A MENACING US WITH THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AGAINST US.
AND DELETING.
EITHER LINCOLN'S BIRTHDAY.
OR WASHINGTON'S BIRTHDAY.
ARE WE IN COMPETITION TO BE THE
LAUGHINGSTOCK OF THE UNITED
STATES.
ARE WE GOING THAT FAR TO THE
LEFT.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE.
INTERNATIONALISTS
SOCIALIST
WORKERS DAY.
MAYDAY.
AND LOWER.
AND MAYBE DELETE.
LINCOLN'S BIRTHDAY.
AND OR WASHINGTON'S BIRTHDAY.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS INSANE.
THIS IS ON AMERICAN.
AND FOR FOLKS WHO THINK.
BUT THE U. S. WON THE COLD WAR
WITH THE SOVIET UNION.
THIS MAKES IT SOUND LIKE WE'RE
GOING IN THE OTHER DIRECTION.
BUT INDEED CALIFORNIA'S
KOWTOWING TO THE SOVIET
DOMINATION.
OF THE COLD WAR.
AND INDEED.
IN THAT KITCHEN DEBATE.
KHRUSHCHEV HAD WITH NIXON.
ALMIGHTY GOD.
KHRUSHCHEV RIGHT.
MR AUTHOR.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
STIR SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
I VOTE.
QUIRK LONGER ALL. ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE DEVELOPED
MISTER SANTIAGO MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR IS PASS AND
RETAIN.
MEMBERS.
THERE WAS WORD FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FIVE.
THAT IS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO
BY DR QUIRK THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO ME BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK ACT
RELATED. CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES.
DR QUIRK.
YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO MAKES IT
EASIER FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
FREEZE THEIR CREDIT HISTORY.
PICKED HIMSELF FROM THEFT AND
FRAUD.
OUR LAST YEAR'S EQUIFAX ATTACK.
OF ONE OF THE BIG THREE CONSUMER
REAP A.
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES.
REVEALED OVER FORTY ONE FORTY
FIVE AND POINT FIVE MILLION.
CURED SAYS SECURITY NUMBERS TO
THIEVES.
CALIFORNIANS CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES WITH CREDIT FREEZES
OF THE PROCESSES
COMPLICATED. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
TWO WOULD PROTECT CALIFORNIANS.
BY ALLOWING THEM TO PLACE ONE
CALL OR MAKE ONE ELECTRONIC
REQUEST AND FREEZE ALL THEIR
CREDIT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DIDN'T THINK IT EXPERTS SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT AYE
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SIX AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT BY MISS HER WHEN CORPORATE
SO MIDDLE TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER IRWIN
ACRYLATE PRIVACY.
MISS IRWIN YOU MAY OPEN.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX SEVEN VA WHICH
REQUIRES CERTAIN DATA BREACH
NOTIFICATIONS.
TO EXPLAIN TO A CONSUMER THEIR
ABILITY TO PLACE A SECURITY
FREEZE THEIR CREDIT FILE.
WITH LARGE SCALE DATA BREACHES
LIKE THE EQUIFAX BREACH BECOMING
THE NORM OUR RESPONSE TO
IDENTITY THEFT MUST BE MORE
THOUGHTFUL.
WHILE DATA BREACH NOTIFICATIONS
PROVIDE IMPORTANT INFORMATION
INCLUDING CONTACT INFORMATION
FOR A CONSUMER CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES. THEY DO NOT DESCRIBE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
PREVENT FINANCIAL FRAUD.
SECURITY FREEZE THIS BILL PASSED
THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM OR CLUB THE ROLL-ON IS
OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW EVEN AYE
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO.
CORKERY.
THE SWIMMING POOL TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CAREER ON OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MS CARILLO EMAIL BUT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PERCENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
TWO. WHICH WHICH WILL HELP OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES GROW OUR
WORKFORCE AN EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOY
PEOPLE WHO FACE BARRIERS OF
EMPLOYMENT. OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE CONFRONTING
CHALLENGES IN SUPPORTING
ECONOMIC STABILITY IN SECURING
AMONG SOME OF OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO WILL UPDATE
STATE LAW TO EXPAND MAXIMUM
VALUE PREFERENCE ALLOWED FOR
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES. IN SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES AND IN AN INCREASE
THE PERCENTAGE PREFERENCE FOR
THOSE ENTERPRISES AND LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES WHEN THEY BID
ON CERTAIN PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTS.
THIS CHANGE WILL PROMOTE AND UP
LEFT OUR BUSINESSES THAT
DISTINGUISH THEMSELVES BY
PROMOTING A POSITIVE SOCIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT.
I ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT THING
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY. TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AND AVOID
INCONSISTENCIES WHAT THE STATE'S
PARKER MY PREFERENCES PROGRAM
WHILE STILL ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN
ESTABLISHING AND APPLYING. FOR
THESE PROGRAMS
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONTRACT CITIES ASSOCIATION.
KITCHENS OF GOOD AND SEVERAL
REGIONAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS CHRISTINE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTERS
HAD A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FIVE.
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES GOING TO
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT.
WE DISPENSE WITH FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
FORTY IN ONE FORTY ONE WE
DISPENSE OF FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
TO PASS RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY THREE
THROUGH ONE FORTY.
SIX
.
MEMBERS WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN A ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT HOUSE RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY NINE THROUGH ONE
NINETY TWO.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTIES FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
ACR ONE NINETY SEVEN THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE NINETY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER JONES SAWYER
RELATIVE TO CHILDREN. MISTER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ACR ONE NINETY SEVEN
ENCOURAGES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE AWAY FROM
USING THE TERM AT RISK.
AT TO TO LABEL OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH THE TERM AT
RISK IS USED TO LABEL CHILDREN
WHOSE ENVIRONMENT INCREASES
THEIR CHANCES OF ACADEMIC
FAILURE. DRUG ABUSE AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS TERM COMES FROM A MINDSET
OF DEFICIT THE FOCUS ON WHAT
CHILDREN LACK IN ORDER TO
SUCCEED. MANY EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS RECOGNIZE THE
POTENTIAL.
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF USING THIS
LABEL ARE NOW USING TO STRENGTH
BASE TERM AT PROMISE.
THE TERM AT PROMISE FOCUSING ON
A CHILD'S INDIVIDUAL STRENGTHS
AND IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO SUCCEED.
STATE SHOULD THINK OF ALL
CHILDREN AS AT PROMISE FOR
SUCCESS AS OPPOSED TO AT RISK.
FORCE FAILURE MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I REQUEST THE FIRST ROW BE
OPEN FOR COST.
THANK YOU MISS JONES SAWYER.
SEEMED KNOW DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MISTER JONES
SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS
YES REFERRAL. FIRST RULE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
NEMESIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
WHEN NINETY SEVEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FORTY
EIGHT COAUTHORS AT ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
ACR TO NINETEEN CORPORATE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER RELATIVE TO SECOND
CHANCES MONTH.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU MAKE IT
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ACR TO NINETEEN RECOGNIZES JUNE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A SECOND
CHANCES MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS SEE ACR IS NEEDED TO
EXPRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATED TO
FORMALLY INCARCERATED BACK INTO
SOCIETY IN ORDER TO PREVENT
RECIDIVISM AND BUILD STRONGER
COMMUNITIES.
HAVE NO CRIMINAL RECORD IS A
BARRIER TO OBTAINING HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
RESULTING IN MISS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CHANCE OF
A BETTER LIFE. DESIGNATING JUNE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A SECOND
CHANCES MARK WHICH SHOWED THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
INTEGRATION AND MAKING OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER MEMBERS LED US
USED AS EXAMPLES SET BY
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN PROVIDING A SECOND
CHANCE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE
THOUGH.
THE IMAGE JONES SAWYER.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
JONES SAWYER YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. YES
FIRST ROW WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CORP UP THE ROLE.
CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR FORTY FIVE
COAUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY NINE
THROUGH ONE NINETY TO PASS A
RETAIN MEMBERS WORD FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE NINETY THREE. AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE BY MISTER O'DONNELL
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
O'DONNELL ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SURE DONALD THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE WHICH REQUIRES PET STORE
OPERATORS TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS.
WITH SPECIFIC INFORMATION ABOUT
THE ANIMALS THEY ARE SELLING.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP MEASURE TO
LAST YEAR'S A. B. FORTY FIVE.
WHICH BEGINNING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN REQUIRES PET STORES
SELLING DOGS CATS AND RABBITS TO
SOURCE THOSE ANIMALS FROM
SHELTERS OR NONPROFIT. RESCUE
ORGANIZATIONS.
AB FORTY FIVE EXEMPTED PET
STORES FROM A NUMBER OF WARRANTY
LAWS WITH THE PROMISE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
RECAST THE PROVISIONS THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. MEANING THIS
YEAR.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROMISE AND
SIMPLY ENSURES THAT PET STORES
ARE STILL REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS.
PURCHASING ANIMALS UNDER AB
FORTY THE AB FORTY FIVE SALES
MODEL.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL. I'M. NOT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS OUT OF
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WERE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY.
COOPERATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR FIFTY BY
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK AN ACCOLADE
TO ELECTRICALLY CONDUCT
CONDUCTED BALLOONS.
DR QUIRK YOU MAY OPEN.
I THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS.
ARM IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN WILDFIRES CAUSED
BY POWER LINE.
.
STRIKES BY MYLAR BALLOONS BURNED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CONSUMER
EDUCATION WE NEED TO DISPOSE OF
THESE PRODUCTS. PRODUCTS
PROPERLY AND IN PARTICULAR TO
KEEP THEM FROM FLYING UP IN THE
AIR AND GETTING INTO POWER LINES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY WILL ENSURE
THAT WARNINGS TO CONSUMERS ARE
PERMANENTLY PRINTED ON METALLIC
FILLED BALLOONS.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY.
ARE I AM DEDICATED TO MAKE SURE.
WHETHER YOU'RE LOCATED IN THIS
STATE OR OUT YOUR TREATED THE
SAME UNDER THE SPELL.
ARE THERE IS NO OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
ARRIVAL OF.
EXACTLY WORK SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LOVE THEIR ALL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO'S OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY TWO.
THOSE TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE HOUSE
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX
IS A. B..
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE.
THE CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE BY SIMPLY MEMBERS OF OUR
TESTS AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS.
MR BOND TESTS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE
WHICH WILL PROVIDE BOTH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WITH MORE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT. THE TRANSITIONS TO
DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS THE
ENACTMENT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN SET UP
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH GOVERNS
THESE TRANSITIONS.
HOWEVER SINCE AB THREE FIFTY
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE FOUND
THAT MORE TIME IS OFTEN NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT THESE TRANSITIONS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OFTEN NEED
MORE TIME TO DO PUBLIC OUTREACH
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
OFTEN NEED MORE TIME TO HELP
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZED NOR TO HELP BETTER.
ADVOCATE FOR THEIR INTEREST
THIS IS A SITUATION THAT'S BEEN
FACED IN MY DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE PROSPECTIVELY
BY PROVIDING FOR. A MUTUALLY
AGREED TO EXTENSION OF NINETY
DAYS TO IMPLEMENT THE TRANSITION
TO DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS.
DURING THIS TIME POTENTIAL
PLAINTIFFS WOULD REMAIN BARRED
FROM COMMENCING LITIGATION
AGAINST A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT JUST AS THEY ARE
UNDER THE EXISTING THREE FIFTY
SYSTEM.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A
CONSENSUS BILL SUPPORTED BY THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AS WELL AS MALL
DOT ACLU COMMON CAUSE IN ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE.
THIS BILL ALSO RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
POLICY COMMITTEES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER.
THIS BILL DOES VERY LITTLE TO
REFORM THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE WILL
STILL FACE COSTLY LITIGATION IF
THEY DO NOT SWITCH.
AT LARGE ELECTIONS THEY DO SO
UNDER DURESS BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN FACT THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS OF WHY YOU'LL SEE
SOME OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS I
SUBVERT. AND.
IN IN INSTEAD UNDER DURESS I
TRY TO.
TO MINIMIZE THEIR LOSSES ARE
MINIMIZED.
THERE RIGHT THERE THERE'S THEIR
THREAT AT THIS ADDED TIME IN
THIS BILL ONLY DELAYS THE
INEVITABLE. WHAT WE SHOULD
REALLY BE DISCUSSING IS
LEGISLATION THAT OFFERS REAL
REFORM TO THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT?
SUCH AS RAISING THE BURDEN OF
PROOF TO DEMONSTRATE THAT A
DISTRICT BASED ELECTION IS
ACTUALLY BETTER THAN AN AT LARGE
ELECTION.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
SEE NO DISH NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM IS CERVANTES YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
CLICK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS FOR.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
A TIE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX.
KNOWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE SAME EVER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CORPORATE
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY RULE FOR
THIRTY SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO AND OTHERS ARE NOT
WILLING TO THE INTERNET.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS THIS IS CONSENT
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK.
WELL.
CLOSER ROLL. EYES SEVENTY.
NO ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED AND
THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN NINETY AYE SEVERINO
ZERO SUM AGO EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE
I SEVENTY NO ZERO SO WE WILL
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR I SEVENTY
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE ASSEMBLY GOING NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE.
SOME OF OUR NINETEEN NINETY SIX
I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY SEVENTY I SEVENTY NO
ZERO ASSUME WE WILL TWENTY
NINETY SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO.
AYE SEVENTY KNOWS HERE SO WE
WILL TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX AYE
SEVENTY NO ZERO SO WE WILL
TWENTY TO THIRTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SIX I'VE SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE SOME LEGAL TWENTY TO SIXTY
SEVEN AYE SEVENTY KNOWS HERE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY.
ONE I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE SO WE
WILL TWENTY THREE TEN I SEVENTY
KNOWS HERE SO WE WILL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE SO WE WILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN FIVE EYES SEVENTY ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR. I
SEVENTY KNOWS SO WE WILL TWENTY
SIX OF THREE EYES SEVENTY NO SO
WE WILL TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO. I
SEVENTY KNOWS HERE SO WE WILL
TWENTY SIX BEFORE I SEVENTY
NOZOMI WILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
I SEVENTY KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN.
AYE SEVENTY KNOWS SO WE WILL
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY I SEVENTY
KNOWS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY I SEVENTY NOCERA SOME
EVIL TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE.
I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SO WE WILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SIX I
SEVENTY KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO. I
SEVENTY KNOWS HERE SO WE WILL
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE I
THIRTY FORTY AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE OH ONE.
I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR AYE
SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO TWELVE I SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY TWO
TWENTY NINE. I SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE SO WE WILL TELL YOU TO
FORTY SIX AYE SEVERINO ZERO SO
WE WILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY AYE
SEVENTY KNOWS HERE SO WE WILL
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY NINE I
SEVENTY KNOWS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY FIVE I
SEVENTY KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY. SEVEN
I SEVENTY KNOWS ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWO TWENTY
TWO I SEVENTY NO ZERO CYNICAL
NINE FORTY ONE WITH URGENCY I
SEVEN DOES YOUR ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ON THE BILL
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY NINE. I SEVENTY NO ZERO
CIVIC MURATSUCHI ONE TWENTY FIVE
AYE SEVENTY NO ZERO AND CITY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
NINE I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY
THREE THAT'S A. B.
THIRTY FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY IN THE
VOTE EYES TWENTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY SIX THAT MEASURE FAILS.
AND MISTER SANTIAGO NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD
GLORIA AS FORTY AND BIRTHDAY.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY ELEVENTH THE
FLOOR SESSION A CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY MAY FOURTEENTH.
FLOOR SESSION ONE PM IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WHERE AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR REMOVE.
OUR CONVERSATION FROM THE GREEN
CARPET
MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT.
IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART.
THAT I WANTED THAT THAT I'D LIKE
TO END THIS.
SESSION.
IN HONOR OF TIMOTHY STANFORD DEL
CAMBER A.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON APRIL FIFTH?
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AT HIS
HOME IN PALM DEL.
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE DARCI.
AND HIS CHILDREN MANY OF THE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
TIM WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA.
JUNE SIX
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE.
HE ATTENDED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THEN TRANSFER TO CAL STATE
FULLERTON WILLIE OBTAINED.
A BA IN ETHNIC STUDIES.
HE WAS POOR.
HE WAS HIRED FIRST HAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE WE FIRST
GOT HIS CAREER STARTED IN THE
BUS OPERATOR.
TEN YEARS INTEREST CAREER HE
BECAME A UNION STEWARD.
FOR THE UNITED TRANSPORTATION
UNION NOW KNOWN AS SMART.
AND THE REST IS HISTORY.
TIM'S A KIND SPIRIT.
HIS PROFESSIONAL THIS POSITION.
AND ITS COMMON DEMEANOR WHICH
MADE HIM A TRUE LEADER AND THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND THOSE AROUND
HIM.
AS UNION LEADER TIM ASSISTED ALL
MEMBERS SAVING JOBS AND
GENUINELY CARED ABOUT THEIR
FAMILY'S LIVELIHOOD.
TIM SERVED IN RTP.
AS A AND AS A METRO EMPLOYEE FOR
FORTY THREE YEARS IS A TO
CHAMPION WORKING FAMILIES.
HE'S BEEN A GREAT LEADER.
A FAMILY MAN A FRIEND.
AND WHO WILL TRULY BE MISSED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN.
IN MEMORY OF RICHARD J. MAKDESSI
AND.
RICHARD PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY NINE ON MARCH THIRTY
FIRST.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE IN LOS ANGELES.
THE IMMIGRANTS SURVIVORS OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
SPENT THE MAJORITY OF HIS
BOYHOOD MANAGING THE FAMILY FARM
IN FRESNO. DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
RICHARD CHANNELED THE VALUES OF
HARD WORK.
HE LEARNED AS A BOY. AND HIS
TIME SERVING IN THE AIRFORCE
INTO HIS CAREER.
HE FOUNDED SERVER CON SYSTEMS A
VISIONARY PIONEER IN THE
BUILDING MAINTENANCE SERVICES
INDUSTRY.
SERVER CON BECAME THE FIRST
COMPANY OF ITS KIND TO IMPLEMENT.
GROUNDBREAKING GREEN CLEANING
THAT SET NEW STANDARDS FOR THE
INDUSTRY.
RICHARD WAS A COMPASSIONATE AND
RESPECTED LEADER.
AND A MENTOR WHO MOTIVATED
EVERYONE HE ENCOUNTERED.
RICHARD SPENT HIS FINAL DAYS
WITH THIS CHILDREN DENISE.
AND MICHAEL.
AND THEIR RESPECTIVE SPOUSES
MARTIN AND NATALIE.
AS WELL AS GRANDCHILDREN ANNA
NICK GREGORY AND GABRIEL.
AT HIS HOME IN STUDIO CITY
SHARING MEMORIES OF HIS YOUTH.
AND HIS LATE WIFE DR GLORIA D.
SAN.
HIS GRANDDAUGHTER GABBY.
ELOQUENTLY WROTE.
ANYONE WHO KNEW HIM ALSO KNOWS.
HOW CARING STRONG AND LOYAL HE
WAS?
I DON'T THINK A SINGLE PERSON.
WHO MET THIS MAN COULD EVER
DISLIKE OR DISRESPECT HIM?
A PROVIDED FOR HIS FAMILY AND HE
TREATED EACH OF HIS FRIENDS AND
EMPLOYEES. AS IF THEY WERE
FAMILY TO.
HE ALWAYS WANTED THE BEST FOR
EVERYONE. TAKING CARE OF
EVERYONE EXEMPLIFYING WHAT
PASSION AND TRUE WORK ETHIC LOOK
LIKE PROJECTING ACCEPTANCE AND
LIBERAL BELIEFS
AND SUPPORTING OUR DREAMS AND
DESIRES.
HE WAS A MENTOR AND A FATHER
FIGURE TO MANY AND WHILE HE WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED.
THOSE OF US WHO WERE BLESSED.
TO KNOW HIM WILL NEVER FORGET
HIM THANK YOU.
THANK A MISSION AS AARON. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING
HEARING OF FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
IN ITS RETAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MR IS VERY MOVES AND MR PONTET
SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MAY FOURTEENTH. AT
ONE PM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED
BONTA AB THIRTY FORTY TWO.
I DO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE BONTA ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY FORTY TWO I TO NOT VOTING